hi my name is on youtube i am nigerian
i'm first generation the great thing
about cooking and how it relates to my
family is that it was always a tool to
bring us together i'm one of five and no
matter where we were in the house when
it was dinner time we came together i'm
really grateful that i had my mom as a
source of inspiration she told me i
wasn't yet complete unless i knew how to
cook so
i made sure to learn one day my mom was
cooking in the kitchen and i ran in
there because my mom's amazing cook and
i said what are you cooking and she
laughed and said i don't know i didn't
get it at the time i was like what do
you mean i don't know she said i don't
know just started grabbing things
throwing them in the pot and i'm like
wait what are you cooking i've never
seen you use potatoes like this i've
never seen you use vegetables like this
what are you cooking she said i don't
know and then i saw her bring african
slice that you can't get in the united
states i was like okay whatever it is i
know it's gonna be good because she only
brings a spice out you know on special
occasions when she finished it was just
the most delicious wonderful experience
and it was before i left to college i
was like you showed me how to make that
and she said i don't know
but the great thing about this recipe
was it was super simple to make you only
needed a couple of ingredients what i
decided to do was kind of
honor my mom and everything she had
taught me
about how food can bring people together
and really make people feel valued and
at home i decided to start little sunday
dinners i would start by just grabbing
any ingredients i could get my hands on
people started bringing what they had
and it felt like home and
that was something i was very very
fortunate to be able to create in that
space
that's tasty oh yes